is that really it today we are
friends who are buying each other's
halloween costumes do you guys have any
ideas of what you want to be
i really really really want to be edna
mode from the incredibles i think she's
so funny halloween is the time that you
can kind of do whatever be whatever and
i
love the idea of like expressing
femininity so i don't know i kind of
into that realm and i just think she is
such a funny character that i would love
to be her probably
plus that wig is just like yeah we can
find that i feel like
yeah totally yeah okay what about you
jess i want to be
one of beyonce's backup dancers from
coachella specifically the yellow outfit
okay i will settle for pink i wanted to
be clever cute and still like
be able for me to you know enjoy my
young life wait what if that is very
vague oh
a spooky hoe yes so we're gonna start
looking online
for our costumes first up we're gonna
look up ryan's
edna mode okay we're gonna go with that
one
love it i love it yeah this is cute you
need black tights
okay wait is this a cigarette i think
it's like one of those old school like
classic
oh god okay is it too late to change my
costume
because now i kind of want to be like
one of those like vintage like hollywood
glamour like oh
you feel like this is basic i didn't say
that
oh but you are now not not there this is
a cute look but if you want
like to go in then we will make you
a dapper old hollywood woman
okay okay well you
turn i am i'm like trying to not look
what i really want
oh that's it that's it that says that
i want this costume to say my husband
just died
mysteriously he's a millionaire
i don't know how it happened i wasn't
there however
i'm now very very wealthy what kind of
underwear should i wear with this
only lingerie none you're gonna have to
wear underwear
you might need to you know wear a nice
panty a nice panty you have to wear it
nicely
like not at all no i mean yeah i'm a
little nervous i'm not gonna
i've actually worn this outfit before oh
that's it
we know i want to be beyonce's backup
dancers
but i'm open to anything we can search
for that because it's like a yellow
leotard
yellow leotard white boots yeah a yellow
beret
why make her a backup dancer why don't i
make her the star
you know what beyonce coachella
sweat oh it's 895 dollars
there's got to be a bootleg oh wait 30
dollars
furry white boots
[Music]
you guys are already pretty much in it
aren't you hey we changed my costume
after it was literally done
that's true what do you want i would be
super into being like a dominatrix
five minutes oh my gosh somebody's a
real [ __ ]
i really want jazz to look she would
spit on my face and then tell me to say
thank you
i can't act like i've never done that
before no i'm kidding
i'm not sure the quality of this it only
has three stars
oh and we can't play around with club i
never read reviews
there's so many dominatrix things like i
feel like is this i guess never mind
this is totally a thing that people do
dominatrix is a it's actually a really
lucrative career
oh wait it's a career yes oh this
doesn't have a bottom either
why didn't these things have bottoms oh
my god oh wow
wow
yeah no yes yes
yes do we have budget for that yeah we
do go down we do
[Applause]
[Music]
so joyce your costume i think i can
figure it out
just like get something from pop culture
that you've enjoyed and make it sexy
i have no idea what i want to be what
would we do with this
well you know it's like a look oh like
just this
yeah but then like like a body suit
underneath it
yes okay i'm thinking like uh i'm gonna
type the word
it's gonna sound weird like a version of
that
yes yes what
like because that's what that's what she
got yeah so like
literally walking around all night like
that wouldn't be funny
this is going to be fun
so if we go with this what would the top
be yes
oh yes oh yeah
that's the one that's the one we are
done
halloween
can we just like say we're gonna love
whatever each other did
are you scared i yes you're hard to
please
not even nervous for my costume i'm
nervous for your guys's because i want
it to i want everything to work
like i hate that like when you want to
try something on but you're like is this
even gonna fit
and then doing that to someone else i
know that disappointment so i'm like i'm
generally scared
oh wow yes
demon face wait what is this
what is this thing that says
[Laughter]
all i see is like laces
and fishnets and something that says
this me oh fun okay
i don't remember her okay so this is
just feathers which
okay i mean oh oh i'm sorry i think i'm
going to look we're not keeping this
because i'm taking it after can we trade
it can we like have joint custody
hey can i open this already or should i
wait
okay i'm dropping but i'm dripping this
is gonna
like can't do dripping wow okay this is
just gonna be a part of my like everyday
wardrobe from here on
i love i love this what is up these
these are my favorite thing on the
planet wait i'm just gonna be naked i
realize there's no like body
is that really it wait we told you to
wear underwear
wait wait wait wait thank god
i'm literally just waiting wait wait
wait wait
wait you said you wanted glamour glitz
fashion couture we gave that to you yeah
you gave me body
and body okay well show the boys what
you got
okay well great love it awesome
wow wow i am excited about this
they both knew what they wanted to be i
had no idea yes
yes yes
i'm very excited oh wow
what is this what is this the dark
parade
oh yes body wow
wow
oh yes so i'm like a dark victorian
so what am i marie antoinette
yeah it's just the other skirt option we
got hoops
oh do this one instead i love them oh my
gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
i feel pretty oh so pretty
i feel pretty witty
yes this is it this is a look oh i've
never been in a hoop skirt like i didn't
do
it i do everyone's about to do that
joyce get in there all right i'm halfway
dressed go ahead go ahead pass too much
or
joyce is going to look great we did a
good job i know
i kind of forgot how good we did and now
seeing it i'm like
that we did we did do you wear a bra
with a corset
no you just take it off there's no shirt
for this
the corset is the shirt baby
[Music]
glamour sorry i don't know this is just
stuff
joyce your halloween costume is going to
be like killer i think we should take
off your bra
yo i told you to take off your bra all
right mama i'm just saying why would you
wear a bra with a corset isn't of course
it a broth
wow i
love it this is everything this wig
is literally
it's everything what did we do but i
love it
joyce all right let me look at it
oh my god what's up boys
oh that's a rose i thought that was like
a piece of my head coming out wow
wow hello hello
hi i'm going to the show tonight
you love my lace front it's 22 inches
you can't afford it bye i love this
i just want to try twerking at this in
the club try it yeah you can wear this
out
try it right here
[Music]
oh this is great wow
honestly i just feel like i'm a
victorian sugar mama
[Music]
oh excuse me and you doubted us you
doubted us oh my gosh officer what are
you
doing this looks great oh my god i had
no idea
oh my god i'm so sorry i love
this this is great can i please keep
this forever of course like
i think the point is to keep it honey oh
wow this is so good
it's like you caught me in my dressing
room and i'm like i didn't know anyone
was yes i didn't know it was gonna
happen
exactly this is so good okay this is so
good
the diamonds honey the diamonds i don't
know if you could possibly be
more fabulous than that i don't either i
think this is about it this
is truly the most fabulous i've ever
felt i've never felt so sexy
well jazz are you ready you all gave me
like barely nothing to put on
okay barely nothing to put on i'm
terrified
you're gonna look great i'm terrified
i'm excited i love that we're also all
in black
the first dress we picked did go a
little bit lower but then it wouldn't
come on time so we got like a
it's still cute okay i'm not wearing a
bra with this so
risque
no no no yes hey okay she's ready she's
ready oh
my gosh oh i thought we were covered
okay
yes yes
first of all y'all played me with this
dress
okay skirt dress literally goes
from here to here
walk around with my cat out take a deep
breath
okay but i can handle this yes you look
at this oh
this fishnet thing
yeah i like it you look so
so hot this is a little okay this looks
seriously here
i know the dresses yeah
thank you man have you ever seen me in
these shoes no but i love them
yeah they're a thing they're really cute
i really feel like you could wear this
out like you could this is a look
i would wear this out yeah right now yes
i
this is halloween we didn't look
halloween 2k 18.
wow honestly tens tens tens across the
board the part that makes this fun is
that we all tried so hard to keep
everybody in mind
yeah and like you know what would really
like make them look good and i think it
shows
yeah that's what makes it yeah i love my
outfits i love their outfits
we all pick the same color which i like
so just like
we all have the same aesthetic and i
really like it
[Music]
you